all right Ben
no where are you from originally where'd
you grow up
um kind of grew up all over lived in um
all four corners of the U.S really
but I spent a lot of time in Virginia
what was your family like growing up
um my parents split before I was born
um my dad was in Leavenworth when my mom
him got divorced
because you're dead in prison for uh
selling drugs when he's in the army
how would you describe your childhood
with Mom
huh
I meant
it could have been worse
really it wasn't my childhood I just
kind of spent by myself
uh
tell me about your mom
worked hard
she had three boys
um
I've always had food always had roof
over our heads
mom was home very often but
um
she worked her ass off to support us
this was in Virginia yeah
uh the men she chose weren't always the
greatest
but
and then I'm
been on probation since I was 13.
you like trouble
what's that you like trouble seems that
way it follows me
wrong time wrong place really maybe
trouble likes you
ah we definitely have a relationship
how far did you go in school I graduated
you did
what you want to do with your life
um I wanted to be a teacher
I should be teaching high school right
now
what did you do with your life
joined the army
and
got out got divorced got a felony
something I didn't even do
and it's been like a catapult since then
downhill
drugs have been part of that
always studied drugs the whole time I
was in the army
I'd be up five days around five miles
crystal meth yep
um we did it all through language School
whole time I was at Fort Bragg
I probably haven't had a sober day since
I was in basic training
where'd that take you
um
the drugs yeah [__]
an operation three times and really get
off the third time I kind of took myself
off
got warrants and two states in the feds
no we're good
I almost got out and got away
but I was moving to Colorado actually
from Virginia
was done selling I had a chunk of money
my mom got in trouble
so I went back to go get her and then on
our way back to Colorado we got arrested
and that was painful
that's because everything I worked for I
lost
got another felony
more warrants
my mom went to prison
so both your parents are in the similar
situation as you
yeah
my dad he's a lot better now
he um is he out of prison yeah
um
he's got money he he uh teaches yoga in
Bali
it's a change
yeah we don't talk though we haven't
spoke in 10 years
how long you been Los Angeles
about a year
you've been on the streets the whole
time yeah
uh
uh I I basically dipped out on probation
from Virginia in 2016 came out to
Colorado whereas
bunker down with a girl that I was
seeing for about 10 years
um she took care of me well
with her and I split I really didn't
have anywhere to go so I kind of fell to
the streets
that was about three years ago
it's kind of been downhill since
I knew somebody out here and they said
they could help get me housing at a job
so I came out here
just recently they got me some type of
housing
and my ID should be in this week so I
should be able to go back to work for
the first time in 20 years
what's your drug still
crystal meth
um by choice is pretty much spent all
these days
um
uh I'm not really one to say no so I'll
do whatever it is whatever they
was offered really
but if I'm gonna go seeking something
it's gonna be fine no
uh I'm not used to like physical
withdrawals it's kind of a new thing for
me
not being able to put it down when I
want to is
definitely something new
opiates are a very different story than
a whole different ball games
I haven't spoken crystal meth has been
shooting for 25 years
I could put it down no problem
it's fentanyl
not so much
you're a slave to it now right now I
kind of feel that way
uh I've definitely find myself
doing things I normally wouldn't do
to avoid going getting sick
what's the
most
hair raising thing you've done to make
money huh
man
uh my girl and I definitely go on a car
hopping
checking doors and parking lots for
unlocked cars
um
definitely had sex for money
what's that due to a straight man
things get twisted
hmm
it's definitely one of those drugs that
man if you ain't got no job to support
yourself and you're trying to [__]
feed a habit every day
you're gonna have trouble
I was never much of a thief for anything
ever
and I find myself robbing grocery stores
for food
every dollar I get goes as feeds an
addiction
I don't remember the last pack of
cigarettes I bought
literally every dollar I've ever gotten
in the last three years has gone to
that [__] drug
you remember these guys one time for
money
my girl's been arrested since uh
Christmas she's been in jail
in Denver
probably why I came out here
um
and I met up with this guy
I've never done GHB before
and I took some I was starting to feel
pretty good I don't I don't really
remember much after that just kind of
made glimpses
I know it started off with one dude
and then I got big glimpses and I
remember there being three at some point
and then
but I kind of finally woke up there was
nobody there
needs to say I didn't get paid
um
it's a hard reality of
having an opiate addiction isn't it no
[__]
you know I used to make fun of people
saying that they had to
they had to get high they could not get
high but they were mad at themselves for
one to get high and I'm like I like
literally I couldn't process it like I
did drugs because I wanted to but I
didn't I didn't
uh
uh and it kind of seemed like when my ex
and I split up and like I kind of had
this different taste for opiates at that
point I never really liked downers
but method caused me so many problems in
my relationship
yeah I was
trying to steer clear from it and
mentalities that it brought
down has had a newfound place
I slept every night I stopped shooting
up early I went to work
but still a slave to that [__] pill
your life was more in control on
uppers
I would say
you're not so much a Slave
with stimulants as you are with opiates
the Soviets you might say one thing you
might totally mean that but if push
comes to shove and your addiction is at
in question whatever the [__] you were
doing or saying just goes out the window
it doesn't matter anymore
like there is no getting sick it's not
even on a plate like even if you're
broke you know and you you know you're
going to be out soon
like you'll think and plan and be like
what am I going to do tomorrow like
non-stop Quest every [__] day
what was the downside of crystal meth
well I mean I guess people hate on
fentanyl right now but meth was it was
the demon there for ever until Menthol
hit
um hit the scene
um
and then that's its own demon
not sleeping for [__] six days people
start like unfortunately thank thank God
paranoia and anxiety weren't my [__]
problems
thank God
people [__] thinking every
construction worker outside it's a
[__] hidden FBI agent
I've seen it I'm like man you're not
that important that's what I got to keep
telling everybody you're not that
important nobody gives a [__] about you
like who's gonna waste your time and do
all that planning for what to watch you
no
you know you're not important you're not
doing anything
you wish you'd never picked up uh
drugs opiates oh my God or drugs in
general
that's a hard question
they're my only rested for a long time
like I kind of had this issue with
family when I was younger
[Music]
um
it's weird what the brain attaches to to
find comfort and support
when there's nothing in there
you know we find another coping
mechanisms
especially when you know when the
parents aren't around
I don't know if I wish I'd never picked
it up
then I wouldn't be able to sit here and
have this conversation with you
your kids
you got two daughters
21 and 19.
you either raise them or
for a little while
patience was
in middle school when
[Music]
I left Virginia
I think she was in eighth grade Maybe
the younger one was in sixth
and then I went about 10 years almost
without seeing them
that was pretty hard
is that because of drugs or jail
prison uh a little bit of all of it
I basically left the state wasn't going
back there
hit out in Colorado for eight years
got arrested they let me go because they
said that my warrants they didn't give a
[__] west of the Mississippi so
I wasn't going into the Mississippi
again
that's where they are
so they're pretty pissed off right now
and they think I chose drugs over them
excellent way I did
what do you think people that don't do
drugs don't understand about
addiction
and then people that don't do drugs
normally are very limited with their
thinking their scope of reality
it's one thing to have crossed that
barrier and then understand what it's
like but if you don't have any concept
of what it's like it's almost really
nothing you can tell that person
you know
you just look like a big [__] up who's
making terrible decisions basically
it's not until I started opiates I would
look at people that did opiates and I
like
I might understand what they're telling
me per se but my brain's not really
getting it like still I just hold on to
like what do you mean you don't want to
do them and like you have to like my
brain just wasn't making that connection
I understand it a little more now you
ever tried crack I've tried just about
everything there is
shot just about everything there is
I love mixing them
wasn't the biggest fan of crack
shooting Cokes probably better
probably close to smoking crack
well Dina 40.
what do you worry about what's your
biggest fear
um
probably stayed dying alone
I hear that from lots of people
it's their biggest fear
that's not the same without somebody to
share it
unfortunately it was
in the drug World things just aren't
very
um
uh things change kind of quick
nothing lasts very long
normally at least
what would you like to see happen in
your life what do you wish for
well this would be the first time I've
had an idea in almost 20 years it'd be
kind of nice to go back to work you
think you can work with a fentanyl
addiction
I'd like to think so
I guess as long as I kept my addiction
moderated
thought about going to the uh VA clinic
and getting
substance abuse treatment Suboxone or
methadone
I don't want to see how it's any
different though
might be a little more functional
probably a little more functional
and say they don't bother me that bad
but man I still not the [__] out at the
worst of times
the worst of times
I really lost
more drugs than most people have even
seen
I think there's plenty of people down
here on Skid Row who make a living
relieving people of all their
possessions every time they pass out on
opiates yes they are
every time you fall asleep you wake up
with nothing
it's kind of like that now no matter
what the [__] you're doing
like I literally lost everything that I
own things that were priceless
uh these last three years have been
painful
I keep telling myself I don't want to
quit I don't want to quit
I'm not sure why
is it purely a physical
drug addiction that's that's keeping you
stuck or is it it's got something to do
with your self-worth
um I'd say that's definitely goes hand
in hand
uh one leads to another and yeah
I mean especially when your background's
already marred like a [__]
it's hard to feel like you fit in in the
normal world
I'd gone back to college twice both
times I went back I
I never felt like I fit in with people
that didn't have a [__] up background
it's the best male role model you had
around when you were a kid
I don't think I had any role models as a
kid
I didn't truly meet somebody that I
could respect
until I met my ex
we were together probably 10 years
which is probably the first person I've
ever met in life period And I felt like
I could trust
and then I respected
she tried first role model I ever had
she was like 20 years younger than me
if I had to pick one probably my brother
older brother
yeah
he was always sober
he made the same choices I did
didn't get in trouble with the law
didn't do drugs stayed sober
that was never me
I don't think I've ever chosen to be
sober ever
you think that's something that you're
trying to escape not look at from your
childhood or is it just your it's the
way you're wired
um
I mean there's definitely reasons
I'm having Dad around
yeah Dad don't want to talk to me for
some reason
says I'm too volatile
so I don't really feel that way
but
but as a kid do you think you were
this is just the way you're hardwired or
is it
something happened to you that may put
you on this path
as opposed to your brothers I meant
I don't know
my mom always talks about some things
when we were younger
yeah like my brain just doesn't remember
she was dating this one guy
who it all ended when
some a gunshot went off and we got woken
up in the middle of the night and taken
out of the house
supposedly we were told that this dude
was cleaning his gun but then we were
told later on and my mom had shot him
um
and I only got vague memories from back
then
uh
but
some of them are just kind of weird like
I have these vague memories of him
making me wear a diaper to school
um
but it's really just glimpses
well I guess I used to steal my mom's
clothes when I was super small
and I really don't remember any of it
so when when my mom gets drunk she goes
off about it sometimes
but then when I talk to him when she's
sober she doesn't know what the hell I'm
talking about
so I I don't know
I don't know some [__] happened before I
can remember
where some [__] happened afterwards and
like my brain doesn't want to remember
I don't know
I'm definitely wired to enjoy life when
I'm high
it kind of just makes life
worth living I guess
there any upsides to this lifestyle
[__]
upsides
people say they're free but I I dare
call this free
um I would say that
the only upsides is that it weeds some
people out like
my phone only coddle you so long
then again I don't know it seems like
like I worked down the sidewalk project
and we do harm reduction helping these
people out
you know and the older I get the more I
feel like
the more help you give people
the more stagnant they become
it's like in order for them to evolve
into something greater they have to
go through tough they have to deal with
strife and conflict yeah you help them
out and they start relying on that help
no doubt it's like you just build a
crutch for them yeah I've seen it a
thousand times
you know and all this helped you giving
people goes from appreciation to
entitlement
like that's exactly right
they stop saying thank you and they
start saying where's it at exactly
everybody I've ever helped out in life
has turned that way
I don't feel like I do
I feel like I'm appreciative and I try
to be when people offer me or do things
good for me
but I don't ever feel like I get what I
give
in any shape or form
people are quick to turn
because they're jealous or they feel
threatened somehow
then what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
oh boy
I guess maybe that
you know as long as you're still here
it's not too late to make a change
yeah people get so caught up in where
they're supposed to be
rather than looking at where they are
and realizing that you can be anywhere
else like you're not stuck in this
whatever you're doing
like if you want different just do
different
your life's very precious
it's gone so quick
right Ben thank you so much for sharing
your story
you're still a young man
you can change your whole direction of
your life
we'll see